hey what's up guys I'm pbhd here and
this is maybe the wildest new feature
I've ever seen added to the iPhone
okay so inside of the accessibility
settings of the new iOS 17 under speech
there's something called personal voice
they didn't even really talk about this
at the keynote but it uses recordings of
your actual voice to stitch together a
synthesized voice to sound like you and
say anything there's actually a whole
process you have to go through where it
gives you like 15 minutes of text
prompts that you say out loud into the
mic then it processes everything on your
phone overnight and you wake up the next
day with a new personalized voice where
you can type to speak alright so this is
what it sounds like to speak on my voice
I really think 30 frames per second is
the correct frame rate anyone who says
otherwise is clearly Faking It
it sounds pretty good it clearly is a
little bit robotic still it kind of
sounds like talking to someone on the
phone with like a poor connection you
know but still in 15 minutes to have a
voice that can do anything
is pretty crazy